The Difference Between Hardwoods and Softwoods
Generally speaking, wood is often put into
one of two categories- hardwood and softwood.
But what exactly makes a given piece of wood
qualify as either hard or soft and how did
those definitions come about?
Perhaps the most important and misunderstood
aspect of defining wood as either hard or
soft is that it has absolutely nothing to
do with the individual qualities of the harvested
wood itself.
The most famous and oft used example of this
concept is that of balsa wood which, despite
being literally one of the least dense (and
hence softest) woods of all, is technically
classified as hardwood.
Likewise, the wood of the yew tree, which
is classified as being a softwood, is a great
deal tougher than many hardwoods including
several types of oak.
So what’s going on here?
Well, the basic answer is that classifying
a wood as either hard or soft is entirely
dependent on the seeds produced by the tree
it comes from.
If a tree’s seeds have some sort of covering
when they fall from the tree, be it in the
form of a shell or fruit, then the wood of
that tree will be classified as hardwood.
On the other hand, if a tree produces seeds
that are simply left to the elements when
they fall to the ground, then the wood harvested
from it will be classified as a softwood.
The technical term for a tree that produces
seeds sans any sort of covering is “gymnosperm”,
a term derived from Ancient Greek which literally
translates to “naked seed“.
In regards the trees that produce covered
seeds, the technical term is “angiosperm”,
a word that is again taken from Ancient Greek
and roughly translates to “vessel seed”
or more aptly, “seeds contained in a protective
vessel”.
As previously mentioned, angiosperms include
any tree that produces fruit as well as any
tree that produces seeds protected by some
sort of shell, like an acorn.
According to The Dawn Angiosperms, by Xin
Wang, the term “angiosperm” was first
coined way back in 1690 by a German botanist,
Paul Hermann, who coined it as a way of classifying
members of the plant kingdom by the one thing
they all had in common- seeds.
Although the terms hardwood and softwood are
in no way related to the relative toughness
of a given piece of wood, it’s noted that,
for the most part, hardwoods are usually harder
than softwoods.
This leaves the obvious question of how exactly
one classifies how hard a piece of wood is?
The most common way is using something known
as the Janka Hardness Test, which has been
an industry standard since 1906.
This involves measuring the average amount
of force required to “embed a .444-inch
steel ball to half its diameter” in some
type of wood, with the average used so that
the difference in hardness between heartwood
and “live edge” wood doesn’t skew things
too much.
It is also distinguished via “side hardness”
and “end hardness” (whether this test
was done on the surface of a plank (side)
or on the cut surface (surface of the stump),
which is “end hardness”.
Most of the time, the numbers you’ll see
quoted here are referring to side hardness.
The Janka test itself it the brainchild of
one Gabriel Janka who came up with it after
being asked by the Department of Agriculture
to find an “objectively and scientifically”
sound way to measure the hardness of a piece
of wood.
For the curious, according to the Janka test,
the softest wood in the world belongs to the
Cuipo tree, which has a rating of just 22
lbf (pounds-force) making it is drastically
softer than Balsa wood which has a higher,
but still very low rating (as you’ll soon
see) of 100 lbf.
Interestingly enough, like Balsa wood, Cuipo
wood is classified as a hardwood.
The hardest wood is said to come from the
Australian Buloke (pronounced “Bull-oak”)
tree, with a staggering rating of 5060 lbf.
(For reference, a commonly worked with type
of wood that is generally considered very
hard is Hickory, which rings in at 1820 lbf.)
Wood from the Buloke is fairly difficult to
come by, so not often worked with, though
woodworkers who’ve had the chance often
describe it as being “like a rock”.
However, this is relative to many other woods.
In truth, it can be cut with a regular old
handsaw.
It just takes a lot more time and effort than
most commonly worked with woods.